This video is sponsored by Squarespace.
Whether you need a website, a domain, or an online store, make it with Squarespace.
Check the link in the description below for 10% off your first order!
Hey Guys, I'm Nate welcome back to the workshop.
Not long ago we had a video where we showed you how to make your own tornado tube using a couple of 2-liter soda bottles.
My favorite part of that video was the look of when we had the wirling glow-in-the-dark water next to a blacklight.
I thought that the glowing swirls really resembled the look of the Northern Lights,
But in that vortex all of it drained out and stopped working very quickly.
So the purpose of today's video is to see if we can build a lamp
that gives us that continuous glowing swirl, that I think looks like the Northern Lights.
Here are the supplies that we're gonna be using for this build:
I have a clear plastic jar with a lid that screws on water tight,
A simple backlight keychain,
A low-volume submersible water pump,
Some extra wire,
Some heat shrink,
A couple of on-off switches,
The top of a bendy straw,
And some glow in the dark paint.
To help with the build I also have soldering iron equipment, some wire strippers and a heat gun.
I've also got a glue gun for attaching some small pieces together and making sure everything is watertight.
As a first step let's drill a small hole in the bottom of the container where the cord to the pump will come out of our hole lamp
*drilling noises*
Now we need to cut off the cord so we can fit it through the hole.
Now with our cord split we need to run one end through the hole in the bottom of our container.
In a video where I showed how to build a desktop vortex fountain some people pointed out that my cord-
splicing technique was pretty poor so I've tried to upgrade that and improve it so it's a little more safe.
So instead of just twisting the ends of this cord together, I'm going to twist them then solder them then heat shrink them together.
There we go; those pieces are now nicely soldered together.
Slip our heat shrink over the soldered parts,
Now just to keep the two wires from coming apart, I am going to wrap a little bit of electrical tape around the joint
Now some of you may be wondering why I didn't add a switch in since I already had the cord spliced,
Well I am planning to add an on/off switch,
But it isn't the type of switch that requires a cord to be cut like that.
So I had to cut it just to fit it through the edge of the jar
But now I need to add the switch in a little bit farther up the cord.
So here's how this type of switch works with our wires;
We'll take our electric cord and split it down the middle a little bit,
We won't cut it across, so we'll still be intact . While we're splitting our cord
We want to make sure that we don't cut into any of the wire itself, just through the plastic housings.
Now let's clip in the middle, and just to make sure that it will fit and line up nicely without the wire ever touching;
Let's clip off just about eighth of an inch.
So that we now have a gap even if we lined it back up
One side of our wire goes around to the side, and the other side has a split in the middle at the plastic partition.
Now we should be able to take the other side of our switch, fit it back on and have those spikes
stab down into our split wire
And just like that we've installed a switch in the middle of the cord.
With the cord cut pass through the wall of the plastic container spliced together and with the switch added in the middle of the line
Now let's attach our pump to the bottom of our plastic container permanently.
We want to make sure we have our pump lined up where we know we want it
We'll gently pull it out
And then let's add some hot glue to the bottom both on the suction cups and on the main body itself. After that's applied
We'll lower it back down into place and hold it firmly there until the glue has begun to cool
With the pump where we want it
We can pull the cord back out so it's as tight as it can get and then seal up the hole around the cord using more hot glue.
With the pump in place let's take the cut section of our bendy straw and fit it down into the nozzle in our pump
Now I've got the straw pointed back in the same direction that the cord is going
That's because we're going to be adding a small light
Into the side of the container and we want the flow of the straw to be aimed
Almost directly at that light this way
We can keep the light and the wires coming out of it pointed in the same direction as our power cord.
Now this little backlight keychain is an extremely simple mechanism. It does have a small switch
you can turn or it can be activated just by squeezing it. on the inside of this one of the wires coming out of the
Light bulb is being held up at an angle
So it's not making contact with the power source which is a couple of button cell batteries
We want to remove the light bulb, but still use the casing and the power source
Because of that we have to add in our own switch somewhere else in the line
We're going to remove the small LED light bulb and that will end up being installed in the side of the plastic container up here.
We'll then use some extra wire to connect the power source to the light bulb through the switch
And see we've got our button cell batteries
It says three volts which means that the two of them together is giving us six volts to power our LED
Let's take a length of four or five inches from our red and black wire and cut that off
Separate the wire
These are wire strippers and take off just a small bit at the end of our wire less than half an inch about one centimeter
Now we want to fit this wire back into the casing one on top of the batteries and one on the bottom of the batteries
There you go, I think we've got the wires in contact with the battery so now let's put the screws back in place
We also aren't going to need these keyring pieces, so let's get rid of those
Let's actually split this wire all the way down, so we've got two separate wires coming out of our battery pack
Let's pull off the ends of these wires and see if touching the ends of our LED will get it to light up
And go
We have light
Just what we want to see
Now before we start
Permanently attaching wires together we need to get some good measurements
So let's drill a hole in the side of our container where we can attach our LED light bulb.
There we go now let's use a drill bit the same size as the body of our LED and drill a small hole through the side of our  plastic container
Our LED now fits very smoothly into the side of our plastic container
Which is just what we want so now we can have one wire
Go straight from our battery pack up to the bulb and the other wire
We'll take a small detour through our switch before it goes to the bulb as well
(finally a break for the subtitlers thank god)
Those Solders and heat-shrink should do a pretty good job of making sure that our bulb is well attached to the wires and that it's
Not in any danger of shorting from any wires touching each other however
It just to be sure because is going to be near liquid
Let's use a little bit of hot glue and make sure that the leads on the back of the LED are completely covered
And we have it. I think every bit of exposed metal is now covered with our hot glue
at this point we just need to connect the other end of the on/off switch to the other end of the battery pack and we
Should have a complete circuit
Before I solder these together just holding it together as soon as I turn the switch
Perfect that's exactly what we want to see. on. off.
There we go at this point we have our complete circuit our switch is working our light bulb is working everything is working
Perfectly just what we want to see now the light bulb will go right here
Battery pack will go right here and our wires
Will all run together like this, so I just want to tape these all together so we have one consistent cord
One more step to make this nice and permanently attached is to use some hot glue to go all the way around this light bulb
So no water or liquid can leak out of that gap
(note to self: never subtitle long videos again.)
At this point I think we've got all the electronics sucked up, so it's time to make our glow in the dark fluid and fill
Our lamp we don't want to necessarily mix up our glow in the dark fluid inside the lamp container itself
I'll show you why in a minute
So we're going to be using a separate larger container to mix it up in and then we'll transfer it once
We're ready to make sure we have the right amount but not too much
Let's fill our container all the way up pour it into this container and then add a little bit more to the pitcher
This is also gonna work as a test to see how well our two holes filled with hot glue are doing so far
perfect
It's all the way to the very very top
Now let's pour that into our pictcher
And now let's add mmm, maybe another cup or so
It's not very important. We want to make sure we have enough
But not so much that we're going to end up with a ton of extra liquid in the pitcher
Now we want to take our bottle of glow-in-the-dark acrylic paint and pour about half of it into this water now
Let's stir that up until it's all dissolved into the water
At this point if we use our
Blacklight and hold up against the water turned on we should be able to see it picking up the glow from the paint
There you go. It's pretty faint right there, but I'm in a well-lit studio, so it's not gonna show up, too
well
But you can still see it swirling away
to increase the contrast between the glowing portion of our liquid and the non glowing portion
Let's also add several drops of blue food coloring this will darken the liquid overall but it will still shine brightly when it's glowing
We're not trying to make squid ink here
We're just going for a little bit darker of a shade
There we go we have our glow in the dark liquid and we now want to transfer it back into the smaller container
but we are going to go back to the sink to do that because we're going to fill it so much that it's on the
Brink of overflowing now, let's start adding the liquid and as I said we're going to fill it up to the very very top
It'll be so full that when we put the lid on the jar that should actually cause more of the liquid to spill out over
the container
here goes
Combination of the glow in that art paint and
The blue food coloring you can't even really see any of the internal components the pump is now invisible
Fill and let it overflow even a little bit to try and get rid of some of those bubbles
There we go now as I'm filling
It's just running down the sides of the container, which means it is very full
Which is just how we want it so now while it's still overflowing like that
let's carefully put our lid on and screw it down tight as
You can see as I'm screwing it on. It's actually squishing some extra liquid out
perfect
There we go nice and tight and by doing that we minimize the amount of bubbles that show up
There's still a couple of them, but for the most part
They'll just be hidden up inside the cap and we'll never see any of the bubbling
We have our glow-in-the-dark liquid our pump and our blacklight in the jar so at this point
We should be able to plug it in turn on those switches and have a swirling glowing liquid
All right
light on
pump on
I think we're getting a good effect now. We are still in a very well lit Studios
So you can't see almost anything of this, but let's turn out the lights and see how this is looking
So while we are trying to get some shots of this aurora borealis lamp?
We're having a hard time picking up some of the contrast that we can see with the naked. Eye
It looked best on camera right where the pump was
Pointing all of the glow in that arc liquid right at the LED light bulb
But the LED light itself gave off so much light that was pretty distracting
so to add to the decor effect what I did was take some opaque black tape and
Cut it in the profile of a mountain range
So now it looks like we're kind of seeing a moon rising behind a mountain with some Northern Lights flowing around the sky as well
I'm actually really happy with the look
So there you have it. I think we have fairly successfully built a Northern Lights lamp. It looks pretty cool
There's a lot of good swirling motion going along and that's what I really wanted
I really wish that our camera could capture. How it shows up to the naked
Eye, because the contrast between where the LED is and the green swirling lights is not quite so exaggerated
So it really looks like this slight blue glow behind a mountain
And then the swirling green of the aurora borealis behind it once again
Thank you to Squarespace for sponsoring this video
Squarespace provides a wide variety of designer templates so your website will reflect your vision they've got award-winning
24/7 customer service to help you build the site that you need and it's easy to set up or transfer an existing domain
Over to Squarespace head to Squarespace calm for a free trial and when you're ready to launch go to Squarespace
Comm slash king of random for 10% off of your first purchase of a website or domain
Thanks for joining us for this project today and remember to come grab your hats shirts and other cool merch at the king of random
Comm see you there
Right
Hey guys, thanks so much for caring about our content in our channel so much
It really is amazing to have great people like you
Jumping in to watch every new video that gets uploaded and watching it to the end you really are
Amazing and we appreciate you for that